i finished the season last night i just
want to thank you for another uh fun
ride you know a very violent fun ride
i'll say it like that um so jumping in
carlo i'll be honest i spoke to you over
a decade ago for the sorcerer's
apprentice i didn't and i did not see
this path on your horizon
well i did um yeah no it's it yeah i
know it's definitely um
it's definitely uh different
than the sorcerer's apprentice
um before we get started um i have to
ask you as a fan of narcos someone who's
seen all the episodes it is every three
years you sort of do a different version
of narcos and i'm just going to ask uh
point blank uh what's the next one
we don't know there there aren't any
plans honestly um
they're uh
yeah this is this is sort of the end of
the ride certainly for now at least
there's nothing in the works but you
know unfortunately the drug trade isn't
going anywhere so um obviously the
possibility of of other iterations
exists but but for now
um you know this is it and the way that
i think we went from colombia to mexico
and certainly you know with gemma who
sort of bridged both series started with
colombia and season three then into
mexico we kind of felt like we were
telling you know sort of a cohesive
story with colombia in mexico they were
sort of siblings um as we saw it so it
felt like um a nice place to to sort of
wrap it up with with season three of
mexico
i i totally get it i just think that
with the worldwide popularity for the
series that'd be you know it'd be for me
surprising if netflix was like yeah
let's just call it a day
you know
yeah no we'll see i suppose yeah i know
it's you never want to repeat yourself
and i think that was sort of you know um
really important to us the storytellers
this season
um
but yeah no i hear you and i don't
disagree there are certainly other
stories i'm sure
out there
jose when you got involved in this
series i've loved watching your arc from
the beginning to where you are to where
it ends
but did you have any idea when you
signed on what ultimately your
role was going to be or was it sort of
like oh this is a cool show let's do a
little bit you know let's do a little
i had no idea stephen i actually
auditioned for a different character
and uh and my brother said uh you just
got the part but not the one you
auditioned for and i said oh great i'm
gonna be like cop number three
and uh and they said no you're gonna be
amalo carrillo and i said oh my god okay
and and my brother said and if and and
if they're introducing amalo carrillo in
narcos colombia
they have to talk about mexico if they
keep doing the show
so
um yeah my brother saw it i didn't but
i'm very thankful and very grateful for
uh for everything that's happened to it
uh for both of you i love learning about
behind the scenes or the making of a
series or a movie i just love you know
learning that stuff what do you think
would surprise fans of narcos to learn
about the actual making of the show
i
don't know probably how boring it is or
i don't know i mean film production is
is a grind you know and um i think that
uh you know we've had um we've been
lucky to have
really a lot of the same cast and crew
for a long time so we've got really
strong department heads
who are able to routinely kind of pull
off these incredibly challenging
set pieces button you know
sort of daily basis um
but i don't know i mean gem is there
more often than i am
he would probably have a better sense of
life on set
it's um
it was it was a tough uh season because
of of the whole kovit 19 pandemic it was
really weird to just stop
and then
nine or ten months later
you know restart everything
uh you try to keep concentrated and keep
you know with with with the you know the
attitude and and the whole thing in the
back of your mind but it's it's always
hard to
you know to just keep keep keep doing it
uh
so much so many months afterwards but i
have a funny story
uh about the um
i don't know if it's funny though but uh
about the the writers room carlo invited
me to l8 uh before we started this
season
uh to just talk and and see where the
yamato um curb was going to
so i went there and it was like you know
just
pictures of everyone
actors and the real characters and story
lines blah blah and then suddenly i turn
around and i see the all the young
characters
right
like next to me
and i look at them i turn around to
carlo and i told him you know i used to
carpool with those guys
every day
uh when we went to school because i used
to live in in tijuana and i used to
carpool with the narco juniors that you
see
on you know in this season um every day
in tj so um i just thought it was you
know scary as hell but um but a funny
story
yeah and at the time i'm sure you had no
idea oh yeah we did
oh
sort of we knew we knew who everybody
was
but you know the complex thing is um
you sort of
you have you told me a great story about
or a story about like you would see like
ramon ariano in like like nightclubs and
stuff and it was like clubs or or yeah
parties and uh
yeah yeah i you know
the tijuana
everything was so close knit back in the
90s that that it was impossible for you
not to run into these characters uh like
i said i used to carpool with with
alfredo to uh to our high school in san
diego and uh but he was like this really
quiet type guy that didn't mess with
anybody
uh he was really nice and funny and
quiet and then all of a sudden you would
hear
a horrible stories uh three weeks later
so uh
it's a it's a very complex situation to
to to live in those you know in that
kind of society at that particular time
in history
um i don't want to spoil anything but i
am curious uh about the ending of the
season i've seen the whole show um is
that based on
like fact or is that a sort of do you
know what i mean i don't want to say it
but i wanna i'm
curious okay now um i have i i
interviewed with uh people that were
there
uh at the hospital
and uh they told me that uh that that
he wasn't it uh yeah because he was he
was very smart way ahead of the curve
and it when i when i saw the ending of
the season i'm like oh he totally did
this this is exactly he pulled this off
i think so
too so my last thing for i was just i
had to know uh my last thing for you
guys what do you want to tease fans for
the season you go carlo i don't want to
get in trouble
well no i just think that
for me this is this season the story of
our final season is sort of
um the
this is a story of the 90s it kind of
delivers
the modern era of drug trafficking this
is sort of the season that basically
delivers the world that we inhabit now
it's kind of the origin story of the
world we live in now um in terms of the
drug trade so for me that was sort of
like the narrative arc of this this war
that breaks out and sort of resets the
balance of power and really delivers for
better for worse um the drug trade as we
know it today
i'll stop it there and i'll just say i
really want to thank you guys for a lot
of entertaining television
i like your heat shirt
oh yeah you can't go wrong with this
movie i may have worn it specifically
for this junket because you know it kind
of figures um on that note thank you
guys so much have a great day
you